the ice shelves around Antarctica are
one of the largest uncertainties in
future climate predictions we don't
really know how stable or unstable they
are and if they're unstable they can
contribute incredible amounts of water
to global sea level rise one of the
reasons that we don't understand them
quite as well as we'd like to is they're
really hard to measure
boaty mcboatface is an autonomous
underwater vehicle it's about 800
kilograms and 3 or 4 metres across looks
like a little yellow submarine
it makes measurements of ocean currents
the temperature and salinity in the
water and then the small scale
turbulence that's active in the water as
well it's an autonomous vehicle which
means that it's capable of making
measurements along a predetermined path
that somebody has programmed into it and
then finally when it's completed its
mission come back to the surface to be
recovered and half the data downloaded
when we went out a couple years ago this
was the first time it was deployed for a
science mission and so everyone was
really excited to see what would happen
and then even more exciting I would say
was when it came back with a whole suite
of data that we could then use to look
at what was going on near the seabed
so one of the potential use cases for
auto sub or for the bode mcboatface
autonomous vehicles would be to actually
transit all the way under Arctic sea ice
and come out the other side with a whole
wealth of data that we haven't
previously observed measuring under the
sea ice in any region and in the Arctic
which is so broadly covered is is a real
challenge for traditional measurements
so what we're trying to do is increase
the endurance of the vehicle as well as
enable it to navigate for long periods
of time without having reference points
being able to go under sea ice gives us
a really unique data set to try and nail
down how much these things may be
contributing to future sea level rise
you